[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans point de vue
votre émission de débat sur lefigaro.fr
une émission en direct diffusée sur
notre site que vous pouvez également
retrouver en direct sur youtube je suis
ravi de vous retrouver et j'attends vos
remarques et vos commentaires sur nos
deux sujets du jour
remarquez comment qu'à un commentaire
que je ne manquerai pas de relayer tout
à l'heure allez on passe à la
présentation de nos invités
bonjour sophie de menthon vous êtes chef
d'entreprise et dirigeante du mouvement
patronal ethic merci d'être avec nous
toujours un plaisir de vous recevoir
bonjour adrien mais bonjour vous êtes
journaliste politique à marianne
marianne qui fait sa une ce jeudi sur
les oubliés de saint et vous est
également l'auteur de mélenchon la chute
aux éditions du rocher
allez on démarre par notre premier sujet
vous le savez tout à l'heure à 18 heures
jean castex doit préciser les modalités
de la reprise et le calendrier de la
levée des mesures de freinage
ce qu'on sait c'est que les écoles
rouvrent lundi qu'à partir du 3 mai
c'est fini pour les 10 km et
l'attestation de déplacement et que les
terrasses et certains lieux culturels
rouvre nîmes est alors de bonnes
nouvelles pour certains mais d'autres
s'alarmer et on se pose la question est
ce que ce n'est pas trop tôt je vous
propose d'écouter deux médecins qui sont
opposés sur cette question nos services
archi complet en soins critiques avec
l'impossibilité faire la chirurgie
programmée et d'opérer les gens à un
niveau de soins critiques deux fois
supérieur à ce qui est prévu et ça avec
une perspective de désengorgement qui ne
peut pas arriver avant un mois l'abe la
réouverture des écoles et des crèches
est indispensable quand on discute avec
nos collègues pédiatrie sont absolument
très inquiet de la souffrance
aujourd'hui des enfants n'y a pas que
l'aspect sanitaire comme à prendre en
compte est évidemment la souffrance que
peuvent rencontrer ces enfants dans des
situations où donc il faut ouvrir donc
il faut absolument ouvrir s'agit d'une
fourrure alors vas avant de commencer ce
débat rappeler quelques chiffres
c'est près de 31 mille trente et un
mille personnes hospitalisées près de
6000 personnes en réa et près de 300
morts par jour adrien le président il a
raison d'être inflexible sur la date
malgré des chiffres qui sont pas très
très bon gré main sur le fond d'épidémie
moi je trouve ça assez étrange et en
fait ce qui me questionnent c'est le
fait d'avoir fixé une date et en fait on
a l'impression que peu importe ce qui se
passe que soit plus personne dans le
vide soit on passe à 50 mille cas par
jour
eh bien ce sera quand même les mesures
de réouverture ce qui je trouve ça un
petit peu curieux et je peux pas
m'empêcher de me demander avec un peu de
mauvais esprit si c'est pas une mesure
qui est prise en tout cas une volonté
qui n'est du fait que à quelques
kilomètres plus au nord où vous avez les
britanniques qui sont déjà en terrasse
en train de boire des bières et que du
coup c'est vraiment une humiliation pour
la france de rester confinés un mois de
plus que finalement on se dit beaucoup
trop coûte mi mai on rouvre mais en mai
en fait je trouve ça assez assez
orgueilleuse alors oui alors je dis pas
évidemment je dis pas que c'est juste
que c'est le sol motif elle la seule
raison mais en réalité je trouve ça
assez étrange et vous avez donné les
chiffres qui sont quand même assez
alarmant est en réalité la courbe ne
s'infléchit pas vraiment et moi je me
rappelle que début décembre l'objectif
pour des confiné c'était on descend à
5000 cas par jour là l'objectif c'est
vingt mille donc l'objectif est beaucoup
moins ambitieux et vous l'avez dit on
est à plus de 30 milles par jour
aujourd'hui donc on est quand même sur
un une volonté de rouvrir un petit peu
coup de couteau et un plateau mais
sophie ce qu'il n'a pas raison le
président il n'ya pas que les
considérations sanitaires il ya la
situation économique qui a le moral
la fatigue les gens ont besoin de
soupape de souffler en fait un oui mais
alors surtout ce que je trouve qu'ils
iront peut pas dire ça veut pas dire que
le président a fixé une date d'abord je
pense qu'ils vont le faire par région ce
qui serait enfin intelligent parce que
je reviens là de la roche-sur-yon jeudi
alors comment ça se passe le pital et
c'est du bon nous on a ou n'a personne à
mais on a souvent des hélicos qui nous
apportent des gens d'ailleurs
donc c'est complètement irrégulières
gay sur tout le territoire on ne peut
pas avoir là on l'a fait pour des
raisons que j'ignore mais qui sont
certainement bonne on a mis tout le
monde au même régime
je veux dire à part un village de vendée
où la seule boutique où il ya deux
personnes par semaine et fermé parce
qu'elle n'est pas essentiel c'est
n'importe quoi donc d'abord le stop and
go il faut arrêter c'est juste
insupportable
insupportable pour les entreprises pour
les enfants pour les parents pour le
moral ensuite de ça je ne peux plus
supporter l'absence de bon sens il est
illogique c'est surtout ça c'est juste
pas possible
enfin malheureusement ceux qui vont être
malheureuse les assoiffés de liberté de
la région parisienne c'est nous c'est
qui ça ne ça ne baisse pas ce sont les
hôpitaux qui effectivement protestent à
paris pas tous je veux dire il ya un
alarmisme aussi des professions de santé
etc
donc je crois qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait
quelqu'un qui disait des gens normaux
qui consultent vous savez c'est pas des
leurs démarches les huit même pas les
nerfs je sais pas comment on fait au
ministère de la santé c'est un délire
ils sont sous pression il ya les lobbys
il ya les interdictions de tester je
pense aux entreprises nous n'avons
absolument pas le droit d'utiliser les
autotests interdit on parle des
acheteurs non
michel edouard leclerc on a des stocks
qui n'a pas le droit de les vendre on a
le droit de les acheter en pharmacie le
bizet pharmacie mais il en aura 6 peut
donc on sait pas où les acheter on peut
pas fournir sa aux entreprises ont tout
ce qui est de bon sens tout ce qui
pourrait aider à enrayer ce virus est
ignorée secteur privé est ignorée on
sait pas faire donc on a des dates qui
tombe du ciel
et dieu sait ce qui va tomber alors là
on avait les coiffeurs d'ouvert on va
peut-être avoir un autre commerce
essentiel qu'ils se rallient manucure
on aura peut-être s'arrêter race alors
les terrasses bon va ouvrir un jour où
il pleut kalt et raciales distance
le couvre-feu alors il a été à 6 ans il
va être cette heure il paraîtrait qu'ils
seraient à 8h pourquoi on ne sait pas je
veux dire que l'absence de sens et
dramatique il faut arrêter stop and go
et il faut retrouver du bon sens vous
êtes d'accord avec sophie sur peut-être
une
réouverture plutôt région par région
c'est vrai que la france est un petit
peu coupé en deux on voit bien que sur
tout l'ouest de la france
les chiffres sont plutôt bas alors que
tout laisse à une sorte de diagonale
comme ça où tout l'est est plutôt dans
le rouge en fait mais ça ça me paraît
évident j'irai même plus loin c'est par
région par l'agencé département par
département les procédés et aux villes
paris mais on va en parler mais on a un
préfet dans chaque département qui peut
tout à fait faire les remonter et
décider de voile à 2 alors après la
difficulté c'est qu'il faut aussi
contrôler les déplacements parce que
évidemment si tout le monde fuit le
département où il ya le confinement b en
liberté quand même parce que les joueurs
bossent chez eux ou vont commencer à
revenir j'espère parce que c'est plus
supportable et donc je crois pas que le
peu de gens qui se déplacer en véhicule
en famille il a quand même une
problématique de circulation qui du
virus sans apprend oui mais c'est les
écoles rouvrent de fait alors on va mais
avoir de mal grâce à célébrer ça c'est
vrai alors tous il dit c'est quand même
un motif d'inquiétude la rouverture et
les accords ici c'est je vous ai quelque
chose qui fait circuler le virus mais
mais je voudrais juste qu'on en parle
rebondir ce que disait sophie le
problème avec le gouvernement c'est
qu'il n'y a pas de confiance il peut pas
avoir confiance en nous c'est pas tout
dire non on n'a pas confiance en lui il
n'a pas confiance en nous mais nous ne
pouvons pas avoir confiance en eux mais
parce que depuis maintenant un peu plus
d'un an
on sait qu'ils ne reconnaissent pas
leurs erreurs même quand ils en font
s'allument on sait que parfois les
chiffres donnés par le premier ministre
ont quand même pas des bons chiffres
il est incroyable et on sait que par
exemple il nous a su alors par exemple
alors voila mais jeanine il ya un an il
nous assurait que le masque ne servait à
rien c'est quelque chose les gens se
rappellent vous le dire et aujourd'hui
ils nous assurent que leur campagne
vaccinale est un succès alors que
évidemment que ce n'est pas un succès
donc en fait à dessein preuve de
communication que je pense je suis pas
un spécialiste sanitaire qui dit qu'ils
ont tous fait mal etc
je dis juste que dans la manière dont
ils font passer les messages ils sont
trop il ya trop d'autosatisfaction il ya
trop là rizzoli de satisfaction il ya
trop de décalage
il ya trop de décalage entre ce qui se
passe on secoue ce que les gens peuvent
savoir jean informant est ce que le
gouvernement dit et du coup forcément
les annonces seront mal perçu c'est un
point de vue que vous partagez
sophie oui oui alors est ce que c'est de
la communication est ce que c'est de
l'ignorance
il est vrai nom peut dire quand on
ignore on peut dire non pas et puis il
ya un moment il faut le dire par exemple
vous avez dit que recevrait tendre
vaccin banon il ya un retard alors ils
l'ont dit quelquefois mais très peu et
puis alors il faut arrêter ce délire des
populations à vacciner alors vous avez
les plus de 55 les moines 50 pass'vac
celle la population première ligne 2e
ligne mais qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire qu'on a pas assez de vaccins
donc on fait des plus gros navets
calendrier de prioritaire en réalité
d'avril a priori pas y aurait à dire non
c'est pas une question de fragilité
c'est une question de jeu en contact
avec le public
pour une fois je suis d'accord les
chauffeurs toxiques se taira des gens en
contact avec le public
c'est une question je veux dire on doit
être capable d'imposer aux personnels
soignants de se faire vacciner et c'est
on doit la poser on oblige bien haut les
gens à taxer de la variole l'imposé ça
ne le font pas ils l'ont fait en israël
samedi la fois on et soignants et qu'on
n'est pas vrai que ça marche plutôt bien
oui ça marche et non après ses 9
millions de personnes mais oui mais
après il faut quand il faut quand même
le dire parce qu'il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ont peur ils l'ont fait en israël et
il n'y a pas eu des morts du vaccin
voilà le vaccin n'a pas fait de morts il
n'y a pas une personne sur deux qui
avaient des quatre trombones astrazeneca
je vous signale qu'on va avoir des tas
de vaccins périmés
ils ont fermé des centres de vaccination
laisser tous ceux qui veulent se faire
vacciner astrazeneca
ils vont poids final est enfin je veux
dire il ya une prise de ris tout d'un
coup c'est même pas un risque mais c'est
là pour le coup c'est un brunch aussi
dans la population française qui est con
à l'extrême par rapport au vaccin et que
du coup on voit notamment chez les
populations de plus de 50 ans qui pour
l'instant la priorité à bahreïn ne vont
pas se faire vacciner et bagnac elle et
ses hôtes y aller ça je suis d'accord
oui il faut il faut il faudrait pour
vous le réalisez le gesa ce qu'ils
veulent de l'astra zenica vous faire
vacciner
ils seront qu'ils auront que autant de
chances d'avoir une thrombose qui peut
se guérir que d'être foudroyé par la
foule bruyante rappelle les chiffres
exactement oui les chiffres de
maquereaux il ya un risque effectivement
de thrombose mais qui est quand même
très très très minoritaires par rapport
à beaucoup moins que si vous prenez
l'avion par exemple donc voilà on verra
si ces gens osent prendre l'avion mais
penser que le
gouvernement un peu plus de
communication de promotion autour d'eux
pour redorer en faites quoi qu'il
faudrait donc il se redorer le blason de
l'astra ce délicat crois qu'il vaudrait
mieux qu'ils se taisent alors d'abord
c'est pas le gouvernement qui a paniqué
les gens sur l'astra zenica ces partis
dont les chaînes d'info merci alors on
est sur une chaîne d'information certes
mais les chaînes d'information on n'en
peut plus moi je connais des gens qui
n'écoutent plus parce que c'est sans
arrêt sans arrêt sans arrêt les quatre
oppose le mort heureusement qu'il ya eu
l'enterrement du prince philip
bordeaux 3 heures c'est quand même la
suspension momentanée du vaccin
astrazeneca juste pour suivre
l'allemagne en plus c'est quand même un
épisode lamentable épisode ça qui veut
me this thèse maintenant il ya plus
grand chose à faire pour l'astra zeneca
mais heureusement alors on va aller voir
du côté nos internautes ce qu'ils en
pensent nicole personnellement ce n'est
pas trop tôt cela fait plus d'un an que
ça dure donc c'est un cas la lassitude
qui hélas fakir nous dit parce que nous
étions confinés point d'interrogation
pourquoi y at-il autant de gens dehors
seach bokolo fine et dehors le
gouvernement nous a demandé d'être
dehors oui beaucoup
je me suis lavé de l'institut d'exact
c'était dehors ces fameux il y avait un
petit slogan faire freiner sans enfermer
voilà c'était ça il faut pas faire la
chasse aux gens qui sont dehors parce
que le but n'est pas de l'or t on à il
faut mieux justement être bavard qu'à
l'intérieur il a une armée bien aéré
c'est son appartement ses maisons
situées dans mon département le nombre
de personnes hospitalisées a fortement
augmenté depuis ce confinement je n'en
vois pas toujours les effets gabriel
nous dit on n'aurait jamais dû re
confiné nous n'en serions jamais arrivés
là si nous avions donné les moyens
nécessaires aux hôpitaux et au personnel
médical pas si vous êtes malade est
malade quand même moi je veux bien qu'on
donne des moyens aux hôpitaux mais mais
mais ces moyens d'avoir locaux vides
donc c'est un autre sujet mais qui et
qui réel quand même c'est vrai on peut
prendre un exemple de
je prends encore une fois le revenu en
exemple parce que c'est un pays qui est
comparable à la france qui est à côté
qui a une population un petit peu
similaire les britanniques ont le
variant en décembre qui était quelque
chose de très sévères et on sent nous on
n'a pas remarqué forcément mais ils ont
confiné très durement en détresse est
vraiment pas à des anglais cet éther
qu'ils n'ont pas tergiversé comme nous
aujourd'hui alors il ya le vaccin
évidemment il vaccine beaucoup mieux que
nous mais aussi sur confinement très dur
pendant l'hiver qui a fait
qu'aujourd'hui ils s'en sortent beaucoup
mieux que nous avec quasiment plus
divers l'auteur s'était dit jamais nous
à l'inversé n'aurait pas pu n'aurait pas
pu mais nous à ce moment là on avait
macro meilleurs épidémiologistes de
france qui était applaudi par toute la
presse et son entourage parce qu'ils
avaient décidé de par confiner c'est
quand même une décision qui peut se paye
aujourd'hui
et puis il ya une max une vaccination
massive ça c'est l'autre facteur avait
dans des termes bien sûr l'un qui a fait
un peu baissé alors sur la sur twitter
on vous poser la question est ce qu'il
est trop tôt pour des cons chiner et
alors vous nous répondez oui à 46%
sinon on va dire 54% cétacés
mitigé d'un autre côté pardonnez moi
mais nous sommes incapables de dire si
ce trouble pas la réalité
comment va-t-on des confiné et ce qui
est très grave c'est que nous déconfit
non mal on a confiné la première fois
plutôt bien cette fois ci je trouve que
c'était pas du tout idiot de laisser les
gens sortir dehors et c'est
effectivement pas là qu'on attrape ce
virus
maintenant déconfinement ne veut rien
dire qu'est ce qu'on va nous faire faire
quelques elle veut là on aurait des
confiné en disant ok on pourra aller au
musée avec des à nombre de personnes
décidées il y avait aucun risque je fais
c'est parce que non là on est prudent on
est très prudent en sortant des chiffres
etc
mais par contre il ya des mesures par
exemple aller au cinéma et au théâtre
le calcio où j'avais cas pas du tout
scandalisé que le gouvernement autorise
sa part elle a en réalité il voulait
aussi éviter les déplacements parce que
c'est vrai c'était aller voilà c'est
vrai il faut être maman pourquoi le
déplacement alors si c'est les
transports en commun mois on m'explique
depuis le début concret rien mais alors
ce qui paraît assez difficile à croire
qu'on le prend quand même tout le monde
est masquée dans le monde est malade et
rêveur mais trouverez mes jeux comme
gala seront démasqués alors laissez-nous
aller dans les entreprises parce qu on
est serrés comme des sardines celle du
monde dont métro il ya un degré de
promiscuité qui est collée pur non on
est diminué les rames
parce que comme les vagues du
télétravail on a diminué rats moyennant
quoi les gens sont là vous sert
également
voilà donc cesser ce genre de trucs qui
sont absurdes et qui sont des absences
de bon sens
en plus de ça je reviens sur le métro
etc si vous regardez d'entrepreneurs
pour la république vous allez voir
toutes les solutions des désinfections
possible dans les salles de réunion vous
avez un appareil qu'on mais il n'y a pas
un virus et une bactérie pendant toute
la journée parce qu'ils ont réussi à
empêcher ça il ya des innovations et
tout ça est occulté tout ça c'est
simplement un expert qui donne son avis
et un politique qui pour ou contre allez
je crois qu'on n'a pas fini d'en parler
à 18 heures donc jean castex fera ses
annonces on va suivre ça je vous propose
d'enchaîner sur notre second débat c'est
une info du figaro que vous avez lu dans
le journal ce matin ou sur notre site
les préfets vont désormais être noté
alors de quoi s'agit-il
les préfets vont être évalués sur
l'application d'une dizaine de réforme
dit prioritaire par le gouvernement
alors concrètement chaque préfet va
choisir une dizaine de mesures sur les
70 réforme ça va du déploiement du plan
vélo à la lutte à la haine en ligne au
renforcement de la lutte contre les
stupéfiants est l'objectif de jean
castex et accroître l'efficacité et la
mise en oeuvre des politiques publiques
dans les territoires pour reprendre le
vocabulaire gouvernementale donc en
fonction des résultats s'en suivront
augmentations de salaire et promotions
ce n'est pas tout à fait une surprise on
sait que emmanuel macron veut
transformer en profondeur la haute
fonction publique il ya quinze jours il
nous annonçait la suppression de l'ena
pour l'institut du service public
sophie de menthon vous qu'il c'est une
chance folle parce que on note les
préfets mais il n'y a que des promotions
et des primes nous dans les autres
prisons nommé d'abord des amendes
donc là c'est bien mais ça y compris
alors s'il faut rien
et elle que c'est quoi ce nom mais ils
ont des récompenses mais je ne vois pas
les sanctions aussi donc noter c'est
compliqué alors plus sérieusement qui
note que notre ton ils vont choisir
certaines
application je vous avez cité les
réseaux sociaux etc
ça me semble très très difficile à
atteindre le préfet le personnage le
plus puissant c'est vrai d'un
département
il est issu de la préfectorale qui est
une école très cadré il n'a pas eu
l'habitude de ça il sait pas manager
autrement généralement c'est pas des
jeunes préfet ce sont des hommes qui ont
toute une infrastructure avec eux la
préfecture c'est une institution
j'ai peur que ce soit un gadget et je ne
comprends pas très bien qu'on supprime
l'ena et puis claque on va noter les
préfets bon ça fait partie du boulot
la notation mois ce qui m'apporte
beaucoup de ces qui va noter parce que
souvent si c'est alors ça peut être un
vote de ce genre dans le département
j'en sais rien mais à ce moment-là voter
ça peut être très dangereux et ça peut
être patient je sais pas si jamais on
s'est pas privé qui ben oui c'est sûr la
fonctionnaire je n'ose pas penser à ce
que ça va donner
organisation adrien organiser la
fonction publique sur le modèle de
l'entreprise ça vous dérange
ça vous fait bondir on va passer de
préfet à manager finalement c'est alors
pour première chose c'est minuscule
détail mais quand j'entends les
territoires moi j'ai envie de m'ouvrir
les veines
bon voilà ça c'est fait la province a
dit l'américain mediapad ya pas de les
territoires il ya le territoire national
qui est la france voilà qu'il ya des
régions des départements il se verra
mais cette expression les territoires
que personne n'utilise à parler
politique ce qui est quand même assez
curieux bon voila c'était un détail
sémantique
vous devrez pas les veines non non non
mais sur ce en fait je suis d'accord
avec sophie paradoxalement sur le fait
que c'est un gadget c'est à dire qu'on
nous fait croire que soudainement on va
évaluer les hauts fonctionnaires mais si
on fait croire qu'on invente la rom et
les hauts fonctionnaires sont sont
évaluées depuis toujours
les préfets quand ils fondent pas du bon
boulot ils sont virés vous posez la
question octobre 2017 le préfet du rhône
il ya un attentat dans à lyon limogés
2019 il ya des émeutes sur les
champs-elysées police de paris limogés
dernier exemple novembre 2020 le préfet
des bouches du rhône prend un arrêté
pour interdire le maillot du psg sur le
vieux port limogé donc arrêtons de faire
croire que les hauts fonctionnaires ne
sont pas évalués évidemment qui
évidemment il devrait faire mieux sur
des choses évidentes de ce qu'on leur
donne des missions et que ses missions
ne serait accomplie que s'ils ordonnent
une promotion une prime ça m'ennuie un
peu moi non mais macron festa ya pas
fait moi je pense que je pense que c'est
un artifice de communication mais qui en
fait répond a effectivement une répond à
un ressentiment populaire justifiée ou
non contre la haute administration ça
c'est sûr on en parle d'ailleurs très
souvent sur ce plateau est ensuite
répond à une espèce de prix selon moi de
préjugés qui est que voilà les les
fonctionnaires ne serait pas du tout
évaluer
et l'or en fait leur avancement ou leurs
promotions ne dépendrait que de
l'ancienneté qui est complètement faux
il suffit de parler à n'importe quel
fonctionnaire qui soit preuve qu'ils
soient franchement c'est très rare mais
il suffit que de s'adresser à des gens
qui ont travaillé à la qui travaille à
la sncf qui travaille à la poste pour
savoir que depuis mai quand je vous dis
que c'est un bail à deux ans et depuis
trente ans que maintenant l'obsession
comptable a pris le dessus et qu' ils
sont toujours évalués sur des critères
qui sont ceux du privé donc je le répète
ça beaucoup sur ce plateau
mais honnêtement ça s'appelle les new
management public c'est quelque chose
qui a été mis en place dans quasiment
toutes les administrations
c'est quelque chose qui existe déjà en
fait c'était on fait croire que on va
super c'est un sujet de vous contredire
en tout cas sur les professeurs moi je
vois des professeurs qui sont à 35 ans
au maximum de leur carrière qui se
défoncent quoi qu'ils fassent les
professeurs c'est vrai mais les
professeurs vous avez raison mais les
professeurs il ya une double difficulté
qui est que c'est difficile d'évaluer la
qualité d'un professeur c'est quoi un
bon professeur alors capable de le faire
alors moi je suis complètement contre ça
c'est vous allez avoir des classes avec
danseurs en moyenne si vous faites ça je
pense qu'on va dire qu'on va faire
évoluer le professeur mais c'est très
intéressant il ya une expérience en
angleterre on appris des enfants parce
que les écoles font tout y est un vrai
directeur dans l'école qui a des
pouvoirs ce qui n'existe pas dans les
écoles françaises d'embauché c'est
professionnellement etc et ils ont fait
engager les professeurs par des ailes à
la ville ont fait un test c'était
extraordinaire
les élèves étaient là non il fera pas
respecté la discipline lui savait un
enfant il est terriblement
intellectuellement percutant lorsqu'on
lui donne une responsabilité alors il
s'agit pas de les faire noter comme ça
mais je ne suis pas d'accord les
performances d'un professeur s'évalue il
y avait d'ailleurs je vais vous dire
qu'elles soient évalués ya des
inspecteurs on veut ils sont respectés
les professeurs pas de carrière possible
y a pas de après quand vous êtes
professeur éventuellement vous voulez
devenir directeur d'établissement mais
vous n'êtes pas là pour faire carrière
en tant que tel pourquoi pas vous pouvez
avoir des salaires très important
changer d'école avoir des établissements
performant pourquoi est ce qu'il y
aurait pourquoi est-ce que ça stagnerait
que tout le monde soit au même niveau
alors je suis partiellement d'accord
avec vous sur le fait que dans beaucoup
de cas de la fonction publique
c'est vrai que c'est un peu
problématique le problème c'est que tout
dépend trop de l'ancienneté l'ancienneté
est trop importante
ce signal et fois dans les entreprises
et ceci dit je reviens à ce que je dis
souvent la mission de service public
c'est pas pareil que quatre dans
l'entreprise et est le but d'un
professeur ce n'est pas forcément de
monter d'aller dans une meilleure école
etc
et en plus ça existe déjà par le
concours en fait c'est que quand vous
êtes agrégé qui est surévaluée le
concours parce que malheureusement il ya
des gens le times très qui ont des
postes qui ont fait des études
extraordinaire et qui ont des postes qui
sont quand même pas tout à fait en
fonction de données vous avez un mur
parce qu'on vous a grugé par exemple oui
je sais le payer absolument oui pas
beaucoup mais quand même pas beaucoup ça
alors là vous abordez effectivement le
noeud du problème il faut revoir le
périmètre de l'état il ya un état garant
pas un état gérant
il ya des missions de service public qui
peuvent être déléguées avec de
reconnaître leurs torts mais pensez vous
que c'est moi qui ça permettrait
effectivement beaucoup plus d'émulation
partout et caetera et ça permettrait de
ne pas être à l'ancienneté et je pense
que la fonction publique on lui demande
parfois trop parfois pas assez elle est
mal répartie il n'est pas normal en
forme lundi 18 fois dans les hôpitaux y
ait beaucoup plus de personnes
administrative que de soignants et moi
je pense que ce n'est pas du tout faire
une insulte à des gens qui mérite
beaucoup mieux je pense que ils sont
capables de travailler aussi pour le
privé etc
et que faire des appels d'offres et
permettre d'exercer des missions privées
on a vu le succès de des écoles privées
qui sont demandées là c'est terrible
c'est n'avoir d'ailleurs que tu vas y
aller avec le privé je suis navré pour
vous là pour le coup je pense qu'il ya
beaucoup de causes qui sont ces pas que
cette histoire de noter les préfets pour
emmanuel macron c'est une façon
peut-être déception pour les
présidentielles parce que il a pas mal
renouvelée
les préfets il a fait beaucoup de
nomination il a nommé des prochains
d'ailleurs donc c'est peut-être aussi
une façon de montrer aux français qu'il
a la main qui l'a fait des
transformations et au moment où il
faudra présenter un bilan d'hier voilà
dans votre quotidien il ya ça isna qui a
changé il n'y a pas ses arrière pensées
présidentielles
moi je pense qu on touche à un au coeur
d'un problème très important qui est
celui de l'autonomie de l'administration
et notamment de la haute administration
par rapport aux politiques qui en france
est à la fois une réalité puisque c'est
vrai qu'il ya notamment à bercy des
hauts fonctionnaires qui sont un petit
peu de fatigue et les ministres qui peu
importe que le ministre pense vont faire
ce qui leur convient ça c'est vrai mais
il ya aussi une tendance des politiques
à se décharger sur ça il ya dire à
chaque fois qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
mettre en oeuvre une réforme c'est la
faute de l'état profond à la faute de
l'immigration etc
le alors moi y'a trop dit je suis assez
surpris parce que c'était parce que ce
que je me sens bien ici mais parce que
ce que emmanuel macron voulait faire en
2017 et j'étais pas foncièrement en
désaccord avec ça c'était un spoil
system vous inspirait des états unis et
hong hong et traduire ce pacte système
qu'est ce que ça fait en fait ce pôle
système ça veut dire que pour être sûr
que la haute administration et raccords
si vous voulez avec les priorités
politiques du gouvernement et bien tous
les postes de hauts fonctionnaires
quasiment tous on parle de 400 postes
environ
il change quand il ya une élection vous
changez le chef de la diplomatie vous
changez le chef de la police vous
changez les préfets etc
moi je suis pas en désaccord avec ça je
pense qu'effectivement c'est quand même
plus efficace d'avoir des hauts
fonctionnaires sont convenus de ce
qu'ils mettent en oeuvre mais il a quand
même beaucoup mieux au rabais ses
ambitions il n'a pas osé faire ce grand
ce grand chamboule non il n'y a pas osé
faire d'ailleurs le programme qui promet
là il n'a pas eu de chance après il a
fait beaucoup de choses quand même de ce
qu'il avait promis
je me souviens très bien qu'il avait
promis de revoir le périmètre de l'état
si la v6 il a quand même promis pas mal
de choses qu'il n'a pas pu mettre en
oeuvre ne serait ce que pour les
retraites c'est une chose mais il avait
et vous dites ça sophie mai mais si vous
regardez sur le périmètre de l'état si
vous regardez vous parlez à des
professeurs ont parlé des soignants vous
parlez à des policiers ils sont tous
submergé par le sous-effectif et il ya
très peu il ya très peu de gens dont il
ya très peu de gens qui sont candidats
au courant d'initiatives parce que les
rémunérations stagnent depuis dix ans ce
n'est pas le cas dans le privé dans le
privé je sais que c'est pas forcément la
jouer à mêler les salaires et monte un
petit peu le point d'indicé qui en fait
le salaire des fonctionnaires est gelé
depuis extrêmement longtemps donc la
solution de lui qu nati repli
aujourd'hui retraité alors je suis
d'accord avec vous si ces effectifs il
ya des certainement des endroits où ça
manque je répèterai jamais assez
l'exemple de l'hôpital qui fait remplir
quatre fois le même dossier et où il ya
eu trop de gens les endroits donc ça
c'est vrai là par exemple dans la
justice est navrant il ya les dé la
justice
les délits sont même hallucinant il
manque de personnel chez soi disant
comprennent dogues privés qu'on recrute
des ddd des cdd des cdi
des gens fort mais pourquoi voulez vous
devenir statut à tout le monde alors bah
moi parce que je trouve que c'est le bon
modèle pour le coup pour la pour la
fonction publique
mais pour le coup ce que vous dites est
mise en oeuvre c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui les deux chiens commence à
l'éducation nationale par exemple dans
le code quasiment que des contractuels
est vrai et les contractuels il faut
savoir ce que c'est souvent des gens qui
n'ont pas passé le concours et qui donc
n'ont pas le niveau en vérité pour être
des bons enseignants vont recruter des
gens qui n'ont pas le niveau c'est pas
parce qu'on a besoin de vous mais non
c'est pas parce qu'ensuite dans le privé
qu'il faut prendre des gens qui
appellent n'y voit pas non mais en fait
le mécanisme j'explique rapidement oui
et puis on va les chevilles on va voir
un peu les commentaires j'exclus
totalement qui nous a fait tomber ce
n'est pas attractive et notamment les
enseignants parce qu'ils sont mal payés
ils ont des très mauvaises conditions de
travail
du coup on prend des gens contractuels
qui sont des gens qui n'ont pas le
niveau pour faire le concours sachant
que le concours n'attire plus les gens
qui ont le niveau
il faut tout changer mon sera pas
d'accord alors la marque allons voir les
commentaires et remarques de nos
internautes gaston selon moi cette idée
de notation est ressorti pour essayer de
garder la main sur les préfets à l'
approche des élections
l'aston pense à des arrière-pensées
électorales de la part du président et
l'a noté les préfets qu'ils
quelle utilité je ne vois pas un cd si
je ne vois cette décision qu'une
nouvelle mesure infantilisante alain
c'est a priori une bonne décision
il ne faut pas la limiter au préfet donc
alain est d'accord fakir chaque
département n'a pas les mêmes moyens
pour réaliser des projets se gère
différemment on va se retrouver avec un
système de notation inégal qui va être
une arme de pression sur les préfets
alors les préfets peuvent choisir enfin
demain dans les soins que ce soit alors
département coût adaptée aux espaces
olympe ça me fait penser aux proviseurs
qui sont notés bonjour l'ambiance
alors la question twitter est ce que
vous approuvez la décision d' emmanuel
macron de noter les préfets et bien
c'est un grand oui à 60 2 % et un nom à
38 par définition n'est pas surpris donc
les gens en vie mais a profité des gens
qui nous suivent ont envie enfin sont
d'accord il se dessine mais si les notes
et comment si ça qui est intéressant que
des fonctionnaires des inspecteurs pour
la zone fonctionnaires du dessus qui
note mois à les points de vue c'est fini
pour aujourd'hui merci chers internautes
de nous avoir suivis merci à nos invités
sophie de menthon et adrien bateaux a
agi droite voilà moi ce film est
vraiment très court vous savez que à
propos des vaccins on nous a dit que ça
y est meilleure sur le stop que vite
qu'on allait etc
cette annonce est à bruxelles évidemment
une se passe rien et bien mardi une
entreprise privée à mais le premier qr
codes en route et donc dans les
conditions de confidentialité absolue
mardi dès 10h dans la mairie du viième
pour commencer vous aurez votre petite
carte votre cuillère code sur votre
téléphone
et ce sera quand même une avancée
technologique importante j'aurais pâte
sans aucune captation des données et
c'est le privé qui l'a fait c'est le
public qui parle essais privés qu'il
fait bon merci sophy on se retrouve dans
15 jours ensemble à 18 heures vous
pouvez suivre en direct sur figaro live
les annonces du premier ministre sur les
modalités et le calendrier de
confinement et on se retrouve demain
même heure même endroit pour point de
vue et bonne soirée au revoir
[Musique]